abramovich has been sanctioned and it is
important that he doesn't benefit from
the club our priority is to ensure that
the club is protected that the fans are
protected and the national game and the
integrity of the club the club can still
play those are the existing tickets can
still go and see the club play
and that that is our priority that the
integrity of the club remains intact but
can abramovich benefit from revenue that
the club may earn no which is
why we've taken the measures in terms of
the license that we have
joining me from the chelsea stadium
stanford bridge is sky sports news
reporter rebecca williams so becky how
is this news being received there
a lot of the fans here are pretty angry
because it means that they possibly will
not be able to watch their side play
it's a glorious day down here and on the
face of it everything seems
pretty normal but actually nobody is
allowed inside this club apart from
staff at the moment and just outside
stanford bridge they put out a whole
media pen because as you can imagine
there's an awful lot of interest in this
story
as you were saying earlier on these
sanctions have imposed it's not an
overall surprise that roman abramovich
has been sanctioned he put the club up
for sale last month that now cannot go
ahead
but what it also means is that club are
not allowed to sell any merchandise in
fact outside the shop today there's a
sign saying that it will be closed until
further notice given the circumstances
they cannot sell match day tickets it's
only those who've got season tickets
that will be able to attend but games
can go on so for example the chelsea
men's side can play norwich tonight the
women's side are going to be playing
west ham
but it does have a massive impact on
this club and we know that the shirt
sponsors three mobile is now reviewing
its relationship with the club and
certainly when sponsors start to you
know rally perhaps against the club then
it has issues in terms of its business
plan but yeah looking at the people that
have come down here today there's
certainly a few fans that are milling
around lots of them are pretty worried
about whether chelsea football club will
ever be the same again
one of those i spoke to a man and his
young son was the last one to buy a
shirt before the shop shot here's what
they've had to say
i'm worried about my club and today i'm
disappointed honestly i came here all
the way from malaysia you know and today
we can't get the opportunity to come and
take pictures in front of our own
beloved stadium i'm not really worried i
mean hopefully the government
come to some sense i can't really
confirm that like yeah i'm kind of go to
the feminist because it puts the fans in
quite an awkward position i could see it
coming um but uh my main point of view
is i think it's quite harsh punishing
the fans not being able to buy tickets
now this situation clearly hasn't
happened before so there are still a lot
of unknowns there is a possibility that
the government will allow a sale of the
club so long as roman abramovich does
not profit from it but you know there's
a lot at stake here it's not just the
men's side the very high profile men's
side but the women's side have been
incredibly successful in recent years um
under emma hayes their manager they won
the women's super league last season and
obviously that you've then got academy
sides as well and all the people who
work at chelsea and go into you know
creating and producing at this club
obviously for the government there's a
lot for them to weigh up they've got to
look at chelsea as you know part of the
cultural heritage of this country but at
the same time they want to make a very
firm stance coming down on oligarchs
such as roman abramovich and you know
they've been talking about seizing
assets in recent weeks and that has now
happened